now performing weekends from their album
another life give it up for Big Time
[Applause]
[Music]
Rush I know it's a weak
night it's been a minute since you with
a
rep something don't seem right
we used to talk every day now it's once
in a
while in a while it's funny how every
word I ate made my stomach ache was it
all for nothing must be my
mistake this R around got me in a state
over compensate I was what you wanted
you even look my way can you just let me
know oh why so hot and cold
I want to know the reason you only call
me on the weekend either love me or let
me go say but you don't I want to know
the
reason you only call me on the
weekend I can see you posting on your
page there you go go while the
G maybe we're just on different ways
maybe the you are new has changed just I
don't want to believe it I don't want to
believe it it's funny how every word I
ate made my stomach ache was it all for
nothing must be my
mistake this run around got me in a
state over compensate I was what you
wanted now you even look my way can you
just let me know oh why so hot and cold
I want to know the reason
you only call me on the weekend either
love me or let me go you stay real but
you don't I want to know the
reason you only call me on the
weekend where you where you where you
tonight you be honest about the reason
that I can let it go where you tonight
where you where you tonight where you I
think I know theas
[Music]
oh can you just let me know why you so
hot and cold I want to know the reason
you only call me on the weekend either
let me let me go you say you will but
you'll you want to know the
reason you only call me on the
weekend the
weekend oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah
yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah call me on the
weekend once more put your hands
together for B
everybody pick up
for another every right
back
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home